magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman so i was
not going to talk about this because i
genuinely didn't think that it would
need debunking that it would need a
discussion but sadly it does because
there is a new ivermectin and again
study i hate to use the word study and
you'll see why shortly because really
what we're talking about is a conference
abstract but there's a new purported
ivermectin study
which all sorts of right wingers
including jordan peterson and others
have been promoting and saying look
here's the proof here's the proof that
iver mekhton this cheap drug
is good for preventing death from covid
they've been covering it up and we got
it we got the information however
even the author of the paper says that's
not what the paper says
we have retracted the paper and there
are now actual better studies on this
matter and people need to stop pointing
to his paper
as proof
that ivermectin works to prevent death
from covid now as many of you might know
if we want to test whether a medication
or treatment is worth using against the
particular disease or condition
the gold standard is a double-blind
randomized controlled trial which
compares the treatment you're testing
against the standard of care at the time
meaning the best known treatment that's
available at the time so for ivermectin
you would take a group of people
you would ensure that there are no
difference but differences between the
groups in terms of characteristics or
that you've uh equalized or adjusted for
those differences and characteristics
you'd give half ivermectin you'd give
the other half the standard of care
the doctors shouldn't know who's getting
what the patients shouldn't know who's
getting what and you compare the
outcomes does one group have a different
outcome than the other
we actually have an rct randomized
controlled trial on ivermectin as i told
you about back in february that study is
called efficacy of ivermectin treatment
on disease progression among adults with
mild to moderate covid19 and
comorbidities that study a good study a
properly done study found
that ivermectin doesn't work for
treating covid for preventing death from
covid so we had that study it was a very
good study and we thought it was finally
time to put the issue to bed
but there is a new study but it's not
really a study it's a conference
abstract and it's actually months old
based on even older data
which is being wildly distorted to claim
that ivermectin is extraordinarily
efficacious for preventing covet deaths
now as a reminder i would love it if
that was the case because ivermectin's
really cheap if ivermectin were really
effective at preventing death from covet
i would be thrilled i have no
ideological horse in this race
whatsoever but we have one good rct that
says ivermectin doesn't work
we've got to be really sure we have
something that gives us a different
perspective well a lot of uh folks on
the internet think it does dr john
campbell who's not a medical doctor
important to remind you has been pushing
the study in a video called ivermectin
more evidence that nearly has a million
views right now
dr pierre cory another darling for the
ivermectin supporters has pushed it
tweeting quote massive study comparing
the mortality rates of patients treated
with ivermectin and those treated with
room desevere shocker
large magnitude reduction in mortality
if treated with ivermectin the united
states of pharma rages on
jordan peterson pushing the study
tweeting
this should be a bombshell treatment
with ivermectin is associated with
decreased mortality in covid compared to
remdessevier
they are distorting and misusing the
report and even its author says so the
author actually responded to each of
these people with comments similar to
this one this comment was a response to
jordan peterson where jacob fimenko the
first author of this paper
says quote hi dr peterson first author
of the paper i think the information and
data is being crudely misrepresented and
misinterpreted this is an abstract not
peer reviewed from a conference i
presented at we did not submit the
manuscript for a reason weak evidence
okay
if it really were shown to work
that would be great
but that's not what its own author says
this conference abstract is called
uh abstract i'm sorry this is from the
eighth international meeting on emerging
diseases and surveillance
and this is a particular abstract about
ivermectin it is months old and it is
based on data that's even older than
that
since then we've gotten an actual
randomized controlled trial
this paper is a retrospective study and
it compares people who took room
desevere to people who took ivermectin
based on everybody's recollections
without even knowing what doses of
different things people received the
paper was also withdrawn
the paper was withdrawn
and what people are claiming the study
shows is that if you got ivermectin
you're 70 percent less likely to die
than if you got remdessevier but the
problem is
number one it's a retrospective study
looking at stated data from the past
about this
they didn't stratify the patients by
vaccine status we don't know
whether the same portion of the people
who got ivermectin
uh are uh whether the same portion of
people who got ivermectin were
vaccinated versus the portion of those
who got remdessevier were vaccinated we
don't know that the study didn't look at
that they didn't stratify for
seriousness of disease in other words
it's possible that the people who got
redesire got it because they were more
sick so of course they were more likely
to die this wasn't double blind it
wasn't a randomized controlled trial now
if you don't believe me
here's the co-author of the paper saying
this
that this is not
good for determining whether to use
ivermectin here's jacob effemenko of
course there are also many potential
confounders
co-factors and so on confounders that
are difficult to account for
in like a large
retrospective observational study you
can't account for data that's not
collected and confounders aren't there
is that a concern of yours in terms of
the strength of the inference from the
study
uh yeah absolutely i mean that's
something that we elaborate on in the
full manuscript that i wrote that we
ended up with drawing um
because you just don't have the space
you know you're limited to four or five
hundred words in an abstract you can't
elaborate any of those things if you're
trying to convey any kind of point
across um but in the full manuscript
that we wrote
some of the things that i wrote down
here
i'll go over
so limitations obviously it's like a
retrospective study so we cannot exclude
possibility of confounding factors
that's just the nature of retrospective
studies
treatment dosage with irvectin was
widely varied there is no unified
protocol
like who knows
how much fibromax in each patient was
receiving
because trinetics doesn't have a way to
you know screen for uh dosages at that
time at least
um
there was significant limitation for the
ability to control for cov19 vaccination
basically we were unable to do that and
that's something we also wrote in the
manuscript
um so yeah basically vaccination status
was unaccounted for um
because trinity trinetics was unreliable
for that because you know people get
vaccines at a gas station here in
florida or like the church or whatever
so pretty much anywhere that doesn't go
in your emr
and also i think most importantly
we weren't able to stratify patients
based on severity of disease um at that
time
you know it's very possible that like
patients that were receiving remedies of
your had a much more complicated course
of disease compared to patients
receiving hyvermax and i think that's
like one of the major confounders of
that study yeah i've seen that i've seen
that discussed a little bit in the
discussions so that's the author
saying we withdrew it
we withdrew it it wasn't peer-reviewed
we didn't even know what dose of
ivermectin people were getting
the studies being misused there was no
control for vaccine status there was no
control for severity of disease this is
not a random critic this is not you know
whoever
this is
the first author of the paper saying
it's not good data it's old data from a
conference in november and we now have
actual rcts on ivermectin so just bear
this in mind because you'll see you'll
go to different subreddits and you'll
see it on twitter you'll see youtube
videos people saying look at this study
withdrawn
non-peer non-peer-reviewed
conference abstract of a retrospective
analysis of data
don't forget
i would love it if this worked
this paper is not evidence that it does
we have sadly tragic news from ukraine
where an american journalist has been
killed by russian forces and another
journalist has been shot
there were there were some incorrect
things reported about this story and
we're going to correct those the
jerusalem post reporting american
journalists killed another wounded by
russian forces near kiev
the slain journalist was identified by
ukrainian police as a 51 year old u.s
citizen and media correspondent an
american
journalist was killed and another
wounded by russian forces in irpin
near the ukrainian capital of kiev the
killed journalist was identified by
ukrainian police as brett renaud a 51
year old journalist filmmaker and u.s
citizen while the ukrainian authorities
initially identified renaud as the new
york times correspondent he was not in
ukraine on behalf of the time so that's
an important detail in the new york
times also putting this out this doesn't
make it any less tragic but initially it
was reported as a journalist working for
the new york times in ukraine was shot
and killed
it happens not to be true
uh the new york times putting out a
statement saying we are deeply saddened
to hear of brent renaud's death brent
was a talented filmmaker who had
contributed to the new york times over
the years though he had contributed to
the times in the past most recently 2015
he was not on assignment for any desk at
the times in ukraine
early reports that he worked for time
circulated because he was wearing a
times press badge that he had been
issued for an assignment many years ago
that's actually really common
um i know many many journalists and
reporters who will just use an old press
pass i've done it as well
um a decade ago um sometimes it's just
hard to get a new press pass and uh you
just use an old one and that's it you're
just identified as press and that that's
basically it
um so extremely extremely tragic story
and it is getting very very serious
there including not only do we now have
journalists who have been killed
but there is also video which we're not
going to play because it's still very
it's still very unclear exactly what is
allowed in terms of footage um on
youtube as well as on instagram and
facebook and a lot of the platforms
we're on but there is now footage of uh
from mario paul
of what appears to be and it has not
been it has not been contested at this
point uh russian tanks just firing upon
um a civilian apartment building now
will the russians later say well we
believed it to be a base of operations
for i don't know they've not said it yet
um and the video has not been contested
so this is all getting very ugly and in
the midst of this we have conflicting
reports on the one hand there are
reports that progress has been made on a
potential serious ceasefire and peace
talks between ukraine and russia
that's good news if it's true at the
same time there are reports being widely
publicized that vladimir putin is now
looking to escalate the war seeking
military equipment from china could both
be true
sure
it continues to move very quickly
and by the
by wednesday or thursday we should have
a sense as to whether the reports of the
ceasefire talks getting closer
is accurate because typically those
don't take more than a few days from
what a number of different experts are
saying we will follow it let me know on
twitter at dpakman what you expect for
the week ahead
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our
longtime sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
david pakman show continues to be a
community supported program you're in
the community when i say the community
i'm talking about podcast listeners
youtube viewers people watching on free
speech tv or listening on any of our
radio affiliates watching on our
television affiliates any of you
and we depend on your support through
our membership program which you can
find at joinpackman.com
we do an extra show
every day for our members and you can
sign up in under a minute with uh
average computer skills
at joinpackman.com
there is a fascinating and disturbing
exclusive story from mother jones and
the story is that fox news propagandist
tucker carlson's recent pro-putin
propaganda
is so pleasing to putin it's so pleasing
to russia
that the kremlin wrote a memo which
mother jones has obtained
and the memo is the kremlin directing
russian media
to regularly feature tucker carlson's
content now
in a in a sense this is perfectly
logical we've been covering for two
weeks now tucker carlson's sort of soft
pro putin apologia and casting doubt on
ukraine and its leader um uh in in ways
that are slightly more subtle than just
coming out and saying putin's great
right i mean that's not what tucker is
doing
but it's still propaganda so useful to
the kremlin that the kremlin has noticed
and is saying let's regularly translate
and use tucker carlson clips on russian
state media when the enemy sees you as a
sort of collaborator in a sense
um you should really step back and think
about what it is that you were putting
out there let's take a look at a little
bit of this memo
again this is a great story great
investigative work by david korn and
mother jones leaked kremlin memo to
russian media it is quote essential to
feature tucker carlson the russian
government has pressed outlets to
highlight the fox host's putin helping
broadcasts
there's even a quote from the
from the memo
which says
it is essential
to use as much as possible fragments of
broadcasts of the popular fox news host
tucker carlson who sharply criticizes
the actions of the united states and
nato their negative role in unleashing
the conflict in ukraine and the
defiantly provocative behavior from the
leadership of the western countries and
nato towards the russian federation and
towards president putin personally this
is a 12-page document written in russian
it sums up carlson's position russia is
only protecting its interests and
security the memo even includes a quote
from tucker and how would the u.s behave
if such a situation developed in
neighboring mexico or canada now what's
missing from that analysis as we've
talked about before
uh is actually different
it's been wait a second for these people
that are doing the soft putin apologia
how would they suggest or imagine the us
would react
if mexico or canada started doing what
russia is doing and i think it's really
important not to get sucked into some of
what we sometimes call these
philosophical black holes or
rhetorical propaganda devices imagine
because
go back to how putin justified the start
of this invasion
putin's entire premise was listen i mean
in crimea back in 2014
more recently when two weeks ago at the
start of this putin recognized the
independence of the donetsk and luhansk
regions imagine
if mexico said i don't know we're
sitting here on the border to the u.s
we're in mexico and we're looking over
at arizona and we're looking at
california and we're looking at texas
we see a lot of people who look like us
mexican americans we hear a lot of
people who speak our language spanish
and
some of them
allegedly want to be part of mexico so
we recognize the independence of those
areas i don't know border towns pick a
border town we recognize the
independence of
juarez or whatever um and you know just
because we don't feel that the mexican
americans are being treated that well
we're gonna send some tanks over as an
example so the idea here of
if
we were
russia
and you uh mexico and canada
did what ukraine is doing how would we
react but it completely ignores the
similar thought experiment which you
could say is valid or not because the
circumstances in russia and ukraine are
different anyway but it ignores the
analogous situation of well what if the
u.s were ukraine
and canada and or mexico started
behaving like putin has been in russia
that one they don't want to talk about
so needless to say
um tucker carlson's show
has become
the sort of thing you would kind of
expect to see on what i would call soft
russian state media
the the stuff that's not like overtly
the uh dictates of the kremlin but doing
apologia for it you see a lot of folks
associated with the left although it's
not really clear why they're still
associated with the left glenn greenwald
as an example jimmy dore and others um
uh increasingly appearing with tucker
carlson and doing what what sort of
appears to be a bipartisan apologia
when really what we're talking about
here is these are angry contrarian
grifters
tucker carlson i don't even know if he
believes any of this stuff tucker
carlton's expertise is weaponizing the
ignorance of his audience with
contrarian reactionary rhetoric made to
make people afraid or feel like they're
questioning the official narrative in a
way that makes sense and of course
questioning the official narrative is a
beautiful thing it's called epistemology
critical thinking
media literacy evaluating why we believe
the things we believe but these folks
have really become the the prototypical
example of useful idiots now when i say
useful idiot i'm not i don't want to use
the term idiot as a pejorative useful
idiot as a as a term
has a very specific meaning which is a
useful idiot is someone
uh
who ends up propagandizing for a cause
fully comprehending the cause's goals
or that they are even necessarily doing
it
um and then they end up being cynically
used by the leaders of the cause i mean
but by the definition of useful idiot
it is impossible to argue that tucker
carlson is not a useful idiot here in
this case tucker
is uh propagandizing for putin whether
he realizes it or not that's that's the
beauty of the term he doesn't matter he
may not realize it he may just be saying
what's going to fire up my audience the
same way at one point it was claiming
the fbi did the january 6th riots did
does tucker really believe that i don't
know but he's he's targeting his
audience for ratings and to kind of keep
this persona of i'll tell you what's
really going on
and that propagandizing for russia is
being cynically used by the kremlin
which we now know because of this memo
and i don't know if the right wingers
who watch tucker find themselves in a
pickle you know they either you either
stand by tucker and you end up sort of
softly supporting putin or you have to
reject the guy
that you believed was giving you the
truth all along so quite the cognitive
dissonance that they must be
experiencing and uh in fact
the next segment is going to be
about exactly the type of uh pro-putin
conspiratorial apologia that we've been
seeing from tucker carlson so let's
let's now give an example right we we
spoke in the last segment about this
leaked memo thanks to mother jones we
learned about this memo in which the
kremlin is directing russian media
outlets to use segments of tucker
carlson's program because it's
absolutely great for them in their goal
of justifying the russian invasion of
ukraine so now russian state media is
being directed by the kremlin use clips
of tucker carlson they're doing it they
love it okay
here is a new
sequence of clips from tucker carlson's
program i believe this was friday night
going going into the weekend
um
tucker carlson jumped right into these
now debunked claims
about so-called uh bio labs in ukraine
and tucker goes right into joe biden is
funding secret bio labs in ukraine and
conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens let's take a look at
the clip last night we told you that the
biodemonstration is funding a number of
secretive biolabs in ukraine labs that
are conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens now that's not a
story as we told you that we wanted to
do in fact we didn't think it could be
true it's so over the top and bizarre
and in any case the administration had
repeatedly and very aggressively denied
that they were doing anything like this
and then they attacked anyone who asked
questions about it as a tool of russia
we foolishly assume that in this one
instance they might be telling the truth
so these claims have been widely pushed
by russian media this is this is like a
straight-up
russian propaganda story tulsi gabbard
fell for it we're going to talk about
that later in the show
and it has really worked to
shift the narrative onto something that
is not only a distraction it's also
untrue the united states has
um uh worked with
ukrainian labs and labs in all different
parts of europe and around the world on
all sorts of public health research
which sometimes includes
research on pathogens this is not like
really a big deal there's no conspiracy
it's not hidden it's not unusual it's
not secret the new york times has a good
article on this and the right is just
loving spreading this propaganda
there are biological laboratories in
ukraine they've been around nearly 20
years
and much like the u.s has done to all
sorts of institutions around the world
the u.s has provided some funding to a
number of institutions with the goal of
researching pathogens
preventing the production of biological
weapons or knowing how to respond to a
potential bioweapons attack etc
the story that tucker carlson and the
fox news uh milieu and others
have misleadingly uh
pushed is
based on some remarks from american
officials that were misinterpreted as
proof that the labs are producing
biological weapons or conducting
research on biological weapons there is
no proof of that and the us is certainly
not running these labs anyway so later
in the segment tucker carlson he
probably knows that the claim that he
made is pretty flimsy
he moves the goal posts and he ends his
monologue sort of implying
that even if it's just research on
pathogens it's by its nature suspicious
it started about being you know
bioweapons and weaponized all this stuff
so then it's just well even if they're
just researching deadly pathogens that's
suspicious too in fact the us embassy in
kiev has acknowledged joint american and
ukrainian research on other passage
pathogens such as hemorrhagic fever
virus apparently there's a lot of this
going on in ukraine funded by the united
states did you know that why ukraine we
don't know we can only guess now by
their own stories about the covet
pathogen research labs remember the
whole wuhan lab story that's where it
came from it was developed there covet
escaped or was released or whatever
by their own claims about that
you would think they would realize well
research into pathogens isn't suspicious
in and of itself and it's certainly not
unique to ukraine
they're the ones who have been saying
it's going on in wuhan
uh and then the sort of like cherry on
top with this tucker story is he blink
brings on glenn greenwald who
kind of like a former leftist kind of
now just a reactionary
um tucker brings on glenn greenwald as
an expert on detecting deception i mean
i okay i don't know about that and glenn
greenwald
echoes tucker carlson's completely
distorted claims about the bio labs take
a look last question maybe you don't
know the answer but why ukraine you know
of all the countries you would conduct
this kind of research in you would pick
one with like a solid medical
infrastructure you'd pick germany or
israel or some place with you know first
class scientific research going on you
would not pick ukraine why ukraine
unless you viewed russia as your primary
threat as unless you wanted to be
provocative toward the russians unless
you wanted to
be in ukraine developing all sorts of
weapons as we clearly have been we've
been flooding that country with lethal
arms for five or six years so clearly
there's an intention for the united
states to be heavily involved in ukraine
the russians say their motive is to be
threatening and provocative the united
states denies that but they have their
tentacles in ukraine and have for many
years all the time which is a critical
part of the narrative that has been
lacking that's right it's fair to ask
what have they been doing in ukraine why
are all their kids working for ukrainian
companies what is going on here
um glenn greenwald i appreciate you
coming on tonight thank you
thanks tucker now of course tucker asks
why ukraine and the reality is
they're only talking about ukraine and
this is actual russian propaganda maria
zakharova spokeswoman for russia's
ministry of foreign affairs i mean quite
literally a russian propagandist
said on march 8th
ukraine has been concealing traces of a
military biological program
supported by usdod
the truth is
there are 59 labs around the world that
handle deadly pathogens as of a few
months ago and the united states you the
us as part of a consortium which we'll
later talk about
um sometimes funds research that goes on
at these labs there's nothing unique or
special about what's going on in ukraine
and remember that a bio lab and a bio
weapons lab are two very different
things and the story
muddles the two
makes debunked claims about operational
on our instagram at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
this weekend there was another one of
these so-called save america rallies in
florence south carolina now i don't need
to explain to you the irony that if the
people who
speak at these save america rallies were
in power
we would destroy america and case in
point this particular rally in florence
south carolina donald trump was speaking
in theory in support of 2022 candidates
now the funny thing is trump can really
only talk about himself so there was
about an hour speech shorter speech than
normal actually only about 50 minutes i
think because it was cold out and when
it's cold out donald trump's speeches
are much shorter he only allowed the two
candidates to speak for like 30 seconds
each at the very end
um and so it was hard to tell that it
was supposedly a rally support
supporting 2022 candidates uh but it
doesn't matter because it's all about
trump trump was visibly swollen his
both eyes were were swollen almost
completely shut i still don't understand
why that happens it's a very strange
thing but here is donald trump
all but confirming that he's running in
2024. take a listen take back the senate
and we are going to take back america
and in 2024 we are going to take back
that beautiful beautiful white house
yeah
i wonder who will do that i wonder i
wonder
yeah so listen clearly at this point
trump's plan is to run unless he unless
he gets sick and and can't run you know
i mean he's going to be close to 80
years old at the time
no no one's health is guaranteed uh
statistically speaking when you're
almost 80 your health is less guaranteed
than when you're almost 70 and almost
16. okay i mean we're talking about math
here but it seems pretty clear that he's
going to run if he can
and by pretending you're sort of not yet
fully announcing it he wants to avoid
having to file financial disclosure
reports that's really the only reason i
can think of not to announce it yet
donald trump then beyond parody calls
joe biden physically and mentally
challenged joe biden failed
to deter russia's outrageous invasion of
ukraine
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage joe biden has done in just 13
months
we have a president representing our
country at the most important time in
history who is physically and mentally
challenged
now
there are real uh the the guy in the
glass house
should not be catapulting stones at
others i think i don't know that we need
to say more about that um donald trump
did address the russian invasion of
ukraine but not as such
he vaguely refers to conflict
in eastern europe
and how lack of respect is a factor in
what's going on
he doesn't really criticize putin
directly like he he says putin has been
driven to put it together which is
really strange language it feels as
though
trump is kind of trying to support
ukraine without really going after putin
and for all the talk about violent
conflict in eastern europe and it's a
terrible thing and we're going to help
and we're going to do whatever we can
because nobody can look at the bloodshed
much longer what's happening it's a lack
of respect
for a lot of people a lot of things but
it's just a total lack of respect
and it happens to be a man that is just
driven he's driven to put it together
and you look at it and it's just so
ridiculous and so senseless and so
so yeah i mean when you hear that it's
like i think he's against the russian
invasion of ukraine
but he says the issue is respect
and putin's driven to put it together
like why can't he just straightforwardly
condemn the actions of putin and putin
himself why is that so difficult
um then and this is where it really gets
to be beyond parody
trump takes credit for giving military
aid to ukraine
ignoring that he was impeached because
he withheld the aid
trying to get zelensky to give him dirt
on biden and announce an investigation
into biden now he wants credit for
having given the military aid that he
was shamed into giving to ukraine
remember that
with
ukraine i sent the javelins that you see
are so effective against the tanks
biden didn't and in fact he ended our
last order
probably it'll get there because
everyone realized it was the right thing
to do and obama remember obama biden
they sent blankets i sent javelins and
they said
well you know what the javelins are the
anti-tank yeah the javelins listen trump
tried not to send the aid to zolensky so
that zolensky would announce that he was
investigating joe biden and then he was
shamed in descending the aid because
colonel vinman lieutenant colonel vinman
outed all of it trump was shamed into
sending the aid now he wants credit for
it
then and this is bizarre
trump calls on his supporters
to lay down their lives
to fight critical race theory
what
who would do that and why would you need
to
who critical race theorists are gonna
kill people who don't like critical rig
what anything getting critical race
theory out of our schools is not just a
matter of values it's also a matter of
national survival we have no choice the
fate of any nation ultimately depends
upon the willingness of its citizens to
lay down and they must do this lay down
their very lives to defend their country
if we allow the marxists and communists
and socialists to teach our children to
hate america there will be no one left
to defend our flag or to protect our
great country or its freedom this is
prototypical
fascist propaganda reactionary fascist
propaganda
imagine even believing you might
even have the opportunity to die for or
i guess fighting against critical race
theory
uh i it's
and this is one of these examples of
critical theory i i am not a critical
theorist i'm not a postmodernist etc
but much like general mark milley said
it's not about
wanting to before or against these
things necessarily it's about studying
them and understanding them imagine if i
said
i'm willing to die against the teaching
of existentialism you would say david
that's extraordinarily stupid it's not
very different with what they're talking
about with critical race theory they
don't know what it is
they know they're against it
but they are uh weaponizing it and you
end up the logical conclusion is trump
saying you might have to die
against critical race theory then
remember uh republicans want to reduce
the power of the president but here's
trump saying we should add a new
presidential power we will pass critical
reforms making every executive branch
employee fireable
fireable by the president of the united
states the deep state must and will be
brought to heal so trump openly
promoting the deep state conspiracy
theory but remember they claim to be for
small government
against the president having too much
power
but he is saying no no no no let's give
the president more power to to have any
federal employee be fireable directly by
the president
trump then seemingly confused about
beautiful blood i don't even know what
this means and pure unflinching courage
is
coursing through our veins so beautiful
beautiful
blood
red white and blue
we will not beautiful red white and blue
blood folks it is a beautiful thing
so trump's rally in south carolina
highlighted a few things number one even
rallies meant to be for other people
really are about trump the the rally was
supposedly for some candidates
they barely spoke until the very end 30
seconds and all they basically had to do
was say how great trump was it's all
about trump number two he clearly is
running in 2024 unless something changes
with regard to his health or maybe his
ability to win the nomination if he got
win that he definitely has no shot maybe
he wouldn't run and number three
he's repeating the same unoriginal stuff
at this point and a big part of his
appeal in 2016
was he was saying new things they were
unexpected they were wild they were
wacky they no longer are that anymore
but there are still quite literally tens
of millions of people who seem okay
voting for the same
failed talking points which if trump
were to win would lead to global
humiliation even greater than when trump
won last time but also absolutely
sorry i hit my mic there absolutely
nothing getting done for another four
years
let's now look at some of the guests at
this completely delusional trump rally
over the weekend we already looked at
trump's speech in florence south
carolina uh these are some of my
favorite clips these are people who went
to the rally i guess we kind of have to
start with he's sort of just a guest at
the end of the day
my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
he was just roaming around the the
fairgrounds or the campground or
whatever it is where they had the rally
and
he has
some new
claims about 2020. it's not even worth
introducing them let's just listen to
what he had to say you know where the
most votes in the united states were
sold so did anyone want to guess
california 1.5 million votes were stole
from donald trump
folks they were stole they stole them
and they're not giving them back second
in the nation the tie between texas and
florida almost a million votes each okay
you're coming for these red states
alabama um john merrill the secretary of
state there john i'm coming for you i'm
coming for there coming back for the
fourth time we found now where where all
the crime was there the in the machines
and stuff in alabama a hundred and five
thousand votes ohio 120 000 votes donald
trump won you want to hear what states
we know he won
here's the states that donald trump won
for sure this should be good sure he won
he won minnesota wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania new hampshire um
jordan
georgia
arizona and nevada
we don't know about he might have won
maine he might have won colorado there's
four others yeah colorado's a question
mark you know it's funny even if 1.5
million votes in california were stole
um biden won there by 5.1 million votes
so as absurd it's like there's three
layers of absurdity here as absurd as
the claim is about 1.5 million votes
being stoled or stolen as i would say
for which there's no evidence
it also wouldn't even change the results
in california i don't know uh here is
probably my favorite clip from the rally
this is a woman
who has been dubbed gigi the greek
goddess
and she says communism is here in the
united states now one of the things i
love is she and the interviewer agree
communism is here but they don't agree
about how it got here this is the i love
when there's confusion like this
ah watching your channel
gigi
this the greek goddess say that
communism is here because the
us the american people allowed allowed
to bring communism to this country
they're allowing it to come in this
country we're not raising it right
and we're allowed this is the best
there's a she says
aloud he says we're allowing and then it
just gets more and more confusing so
what do they do they call for everyone
to be imprisoned for treason people the
americans not to stand up and fight for
a country the beautiful country of ours
and yes they stole our elections
right big tech
soros the democrats the republicans the
demon rats and soros stole the election
guys they stole it
oh they stole elections swamp needs to
go up right now this one i love your
shirt there you go turn around oh
all right there you go it's okay don't
be the same baby because the guy the guy
he is more than that
he needs to be in jail for treason all
of them
their joy and their whole got to go
yes
biden put him in prison for
treason
she says
then trump's uh uh trump's endorsed
candidate to fight against uh nancy mace
trump wants nancy mace out and instead
he's endorsed uh kate arrington
here kay arrington gives us her for
policy priorities so it's like oh hey
we're gonna get some policy from
republicans that's cool let's listen
listen to her four priorities people of
the low country first things we need to
do when we get up there fire fouchy
second thing get rid of the department
of federal education and third thing
start impeaching biden and open
huntington biden's laptop
um
yeah that these are her legislative
priorities fire fouchy fouchy's 80 and
i'm sure is retiring soon number two get
rid of the department of education this
is the opposite of what we need we we
need to we need to save american public
education impeach biden she doesn't say
for what and four open up hunter biden's
laptop now i don't know if she means
just like turn it on and open the lid uh
or if she means like take it apart or
just access the contents it's not really
clear what what she means and then
lastly just to round out the tone and
tenor
of this wacky trump rally in south
carolina here's a guy who said he
refuses to wear masks so he's not flying
because if he flew he would have to
punch the stewardess
[Laughter]
so kill him he'll
he'll die before he gets a vaccine and
he'll punch a f he says stewardess he'll
punch a flight attendant
uh before he puts on a mask so really
the caliber of folks that are
they're not going ironically to the
rally understand that if they went
ironically it would be a totally
different thing but they are
unironically at the rally
we're going to take a break all of these
clips will be on our facebook
facebook.com
slash david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
patreon.com david pakman show where you
can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show so former
democratic congresswoman tulsi gabbard
is getting millions of views for a new
clip in which she spreads incorrect
statements that mirror
recent actual russian propaganda i'm not
using that term as a pejorative this is
this is actual russian propaganda that
was recently spread by maria bakarova as
we spoke about earlier we talked about
this in the tucker carlson segment this
is the hypothesis about u.s funded
bio-weapons labs in ukraine tulsi
gabbard putting out a video about this
has 2.3 million views as of uh this
morning let's take a look at the clip
and you'll recognize some of the same
misstatements from tulsi that we were
getting on the putin apologia show
tucker carlson does on fox news take a
look here are the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the u.s government these
bio labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities even in the best of
circumstances could easily be
compromised
and release these deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders
if they are inadvertently or purposely
breached or compromised they will
quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing
untold suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed now understand
these are not american american labs to
shut down
biden and harris don't run the laps
and so she is again running interference
for putin because that's effectively
what this does
by shifting the conversation into
we gotta we we have hostilities going on
and if ukrainian labs are hit damaged
destroyed it's conceivable that
pathogens could be
released now that part is true
but it's not even close to being the
story of what's going on in ukraine and
of course
the right under the surface thing about
all of this is again because when when
all you have is a hammer everything
looks like a nail
the story they really want why are they
talking about this they're talking about
this because they want to
attack the us attack the u.s
rather than just putin invaded ukraine
that's what we should be talking about
here um let's listen to a little bit
more
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured
and these pathogens are destroyed
in addition to all this the u.s funds
around 300 bio labs around the world
who are engaging in dangerous research
including gain of function similar to
the lab in wuhan where kovid 19 may have
originated from so listen um
she now is talking about
covid might have come from the lab
and she's doing the same thing tucker
did which is the fact i mean listen guys
labs exist research is done that yes
there i told you earlier there's labs
all over the world there's all sorts of
different labs all over the world world
there's a consortium called the
cooperative threat reduction program
and what they do is they research
pathogens
and when she goes from the problem is
ukraine
to the point is the bio labs around the
world
why would we shut all of them down i
mean we we need to do this research is
she's just saying the research shouldn't
be done
there are no u.s run bio labs in ukraine
the country is one of many former soviet
union countries
and non-former soviet union countries
that partner with the department of
defense as part of this cooperative
threat reduction program it's public
nothing's being covered up nothing's
been covered up the goal here is
do research that would hopefully be able
to prevent biological threats it's not
to create biological threats so why
would we shut down every lab everywhere
i i just don't get how do we gain from
not studying this stuff and that seems
to be what she's calling for i i was
reminded remember when mike pillow said
he wants to sue all machines oh and he's
like what are you talking about dude
tulsi seems to be saying just shut down
labs just shut them down and so this is
typical russian propaganda for years
russia has claimed that former soviet
countries are by manufacturing
biological weapons in labs funded by the
us it's an old russian propaganda story
now thanks to tucker carlson thanks to
tulsi gabbard they've mixed in
there's something here related to the
invasion and it's particularly
pernicious or whatever these are not
secret labs the details of american
involvement is on u.s government
websites and this program the biological
threat reduction program dates all the
way back to the 1990s and um there are
no
listen we if you if you want to argue
there should be no bio research done
well okay argue that absent this
conflict then explain why research
shouldn't be done to me it seems
incredibly stupid to say we're just
we're not going to research it
countries are developing bio weapons
we're not even going to research bio
weapon defense what what why that
doesn't make any sense
and uh they continue to make these
unsubstantiated claims and they will
continue because they are 2.3 million
views of a video in which tulsi has no
clue what she's even talking about this
stuff get clicks gets clicked so they're
going to continue doing it
last week i had this video for you of
ufc fighter bryce mitchell
saying he knows nothing about ukraine
and russia and then he listed a bunch of
conspiracies he was naturally invited
onto tucker carlson's show to give his
expertise just as a reminder here's the
original viral clip from ufc fighter
bryce mitchell which we looked at last
week well i just wanted to get your
thoughts on the whole russia and ukraine
situation
you know um
here's my first thought is i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love and i
will not retreat if this country is
invaded and
everybody's saying well we gotta we
gotta evacuate we gotta leave we go i
will not i will dig my boots in the
arkansas soil and i will fight for the
people that i love for the land that i
love and the way of life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really don't there's so
much stuff and i don't think nobody
knows what's going on fully there's been
so much political corruption in that
area you got biden and his son making a
[ __ ] ton of money
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion okay so he said remember he
doesn't know what's going on but then he
gave a whole bunch of unsubstantiated
opinions so of course he gets the hero's
welcome on tucker carlson's program no
question whatsoever um and uh let's take
a look at that coming on and for what
you said
um i haven't seen anybody express it
better than you did why did you say that
well thank you so much for having me
brother and i said that because that's
the first thing that i thought when he
asked me and i was trying to give him
the best answer that i could and that's
just my genuine thoughts on the subject
how do you get to be so honest when
everyone everyone else is afraid to say
what they think really getting i mean
tucker tucker should be blushing over
this guys can you just kind of say it
well i don't have to be uh worried about
being fired from my job for saying what
i want to say there's a lot of people
out there that do agree with me but they
can't say things that i get to say even
though they think them they'll get fired
from their job if they come out and say
it right
cancel culture white's pretty good with
how he lets us
talk and say we want
that is that is absolutely right and a
fair thing to say now people who say
what you have said
are often denounced as unpatriotic or
traitors to their country does that
confuse you since the first thing you
said was i will fight and die
for arkansas
by the way the con they're pretending
the controversy over this guy is that he
said he wouldn't go and fight in ukraine
that's not really the controversy the
controversy is he says i don't know
anything about what's going on and i
don't think anybody does which is a
classic move from these people to say no
anything you're hearing is probably not
true
but then he spreads disinformation
conspiracy theories that's the problem
not that he doesn't want to go and fight
over there
that'd be the greatest honor i could
ever have brother so i'm i'm far from
not being a patriot you know that'd be
the greatest thing i could do is die
defending this land so i'm not afraid to
do that i'm just not wanting to go waste
my life fighting for some of these
battles that i don't even believe in
that's great that nobody's criticizing
him for that
you know where i believe our
leaders a lot of these elites are guilty
of trees and what they've done is just
uh treasonous right and again he just
gets into this this what who who did
treason and what exactly
when in the last segment he mentioned
treason he was talking about joe and
hunter biden that's the treason and this
is exactly how people who don't know
anything end up in positions where
they're telling millions of people about
their ignorant beliefs remember he said
i don't know what's going on there and
then went on to give all sorts of
different statements about what he
thinks is going on and he was wrong
about all of it he doesn't want to fight
great lots of people don't that that
that makes a lot of sense
why would you go over and fight there
that you don't have to do that that's
not the moral test you have to pass
but then he repeats all of this nonsense
and then tucker brings them on to repeat
it again it's really dangerous stuff
that's going on right now in right-wing
media
we have a voicemail number 2192 david p
uh trump's performance on saturday at
his rally was so bad that i got way more
people angry with me for my coverage of
the rally than normal here's one example
david pakman this is your only friend
from cleveland ohio a conservative
responding to your pathetic
performance last night did you
get a pink slip
for your performance last night
no i mean i'm in charge who's going to
fire me dropping trump at your whim
is that what liberals find entertaining
seriously did you earn a paycheck for
that yes you know david trump's railways
are censored
and no they're not trump's rallies are
not censored um
are limited have limited exposure
because of big tech
censorship
that's completely untrue the all sorts
of right-wing youtube channels and
facebook pages streamed the rally live
and had hundreds of thousands of viewers
because they fear the truth and that's
why i got stuck with you
and realized
that uh what a class of shameless
ignorant little liberal
you are
yeah anyway he goes on for two more
minutes but the worse trump's
performances are
the more messages like that i get really
uh really quite a trend that we see we
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about who would stay and fight
if russia invaded the u.s there's a new
poll
and much much more
sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access to
the world famous bonus show much hated
by alex jones oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad
i will see you on the bonus show thank
you alex
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman